what's happening i've been waiting for
you to start oh i'm starting we've done
a fish episode we've done a taco episode
today
we're doing fish fish tacos that's all
right show you off there
steven close your eyes okay you hear the
crashing of the waves you smell the
ocean
air imagine putting a perfectly cooked
piece of fish
into your mouth right now i am
salivating now transport yourself
to under a bridge next to the freeway
14 miles from here no stop stop the
dream you know what happens under
highways
that's where we're going now sketchy
things bro
sketchy things happen at the beach
they're worth it we're gonna be trying
three fish tacos at three drastically
different price points to find out which
one is the most worth it at its price
because steven all of the best fish
tacos are not at the beach
we're headed to silver lake to a taco
truck called ricky's fish taco
listen folk i do not appreciate
having us leave the beach but i have had
these fish tacos before they are
delightful but come on you can't just
bring me to the beach
and then leave the beach beach please
[Laughter]
hi my name is ricardo pina we're at
ricky's fish tacos i had the idea of
making the fish tacos in la
because the lack of original recipes for
ensenada selfish tacos
actually i got the recipe from my mom my
sister and my grandma put it all
together and apply it to the rush rush
of valet
was it something that she was making at
home for you no actually i'm the first
taco guy in the family
i went to school to be a lab technician
but i ended up being a taquero
a good encinara style fish taco calls
for wheat flour
oregano mustard mayo fried and lard i
use a lot more oregano a lot more
mustard so it's a more flavorful batter
yes the deep fryers
all the flavors fly out of the batter
with that kind of temperature because
it's boiling so you add a little extra
in order to maintain the flavors in it
how do you achieve a really crispy piece
of fish
ah lard heats up faster than oil we want
the lard to go into the fish so
i pierce the fish as it's frying you get
moist
melt in your mouth fish with a crispy
crust i can hear your lab technician
background coming through right now as
you're describing the cooking agent
a good fish taco should be able to bring
you back to ensenada
shredded cabbage which doesn't go bad
without refrigeration
as fast as lettuce back in the 50s in
ensenada they didn't have refrigeration
when i started my recipe nine years ago
i didn't stop until
i tried it and it tasted like my
favorite fish taco place in encenada the
smell of fried stuff yeah
the aroma around this truck is delicious
almost perfume-like
okay so we need to sauce these bad boys
up which one do you recommend that we
try definitely the bread it goes great
the smokiness of the roasted tomatoes
and the jalapenos we
crush the fish that go okay let's go
straight down the path here we go
you didn't cheers oh
i'm like a horse that you taught math
here's a controversial statement uh-oh i
think that fish
might be a better fried food than
chicken oh
wow please defend yourself because
there's going to be some mad people out
there
it's how soft the flesh stays on the
inside
here at rikki's this particular batter
gets so crispy never gotten under like a
really nice
new fresh pair of sneakers and you call
them crispy
yeah then you put your foot in the shoe
and it feels soft so soft
inside this is like the best sneaker
that might be the best technology you've
ever had on thank you so good
okay more i think we should do a lobster
taco yes i have to ask about the lobster
taco
is that actually a very common taco from
ensenada
not from mencinara from rosarito there
is a place called puerto nuevo
lobster fishing village they serve
pacific lobster with salt pepper
paprika and garlic butter so i wanted to
bring that that too
lobster cheers
mmm oh that's good i like how this is a
very
affordable wood to eat lobster you're a
lobster lover seven bucks
boom you might roll your eyes at a
lobster taco but if nothing else
this proves that ricky is a great
all-around chef and is not just
in the frying game look he's a scientist
ricky's a fish scientist
yes is what we actually learned that's
right let's get out of here
i think the only thing that would have
made that better
is that if i was eating it at the beach
that was an amazing fish taco
it was so hot and crispy crispy now i
need to cool my mouth down
ice cream chocolate look at that sucker
why does mine
already look worse than yours out of the
bag what the heck you must have squeezed
it too hard
oh that's good the taco shape is great
for ice cream though because
it allows you to bite the ice cream and
your teeth don't get cold fish taco fact
time
fish taco fat annie do you have the
facts
we need 15 and a half pounds of fish and
shellfish per person each year in the
u.s
15.5 pounds per what year that's it yeah
i would think it would be a lot more
no way yeah we got to up our fish
consumption so we're on our way to a
place called holbox
a fine seafood restaurant in a food
court
near usc so once again we are not going
to the beach
correct
[Music]
my name is gilberto cetina we're here at
holbox restaurant in mercado la paloma
in expo park holborch
is a regional coastal mexican restaurant
that works with sustainable high quality
local seafood the heart of mexican
seafood is
fresh ingredients seasonality and
simplicity the purest way of eating
seafood two ways
raw or wood grill we're here to try a
kampachi fish taco
the anatomy of a taco is pretty standard
across all of mexico you have a tortilla
then you have a protein
usually there's a fat component and like
street tacos that's what makes the
flavor really pop
this fish in particular the kampachi has
the fattiness to give you that full
mouth feel so fish comes in straight
from the farm
omega blue aquaculture in baja
california our fish taco is skin on we
try to use as much
of the fish as possible if the skin is
delicious use it
season just with sea salt that's it gets
that very important ingredient which is
the smoke from the fire that smoke
takes me back to cooking fish on the
beach back home
in the yucatan while the fish is cooking
masa made for us by
a molino in east l.a that's been doing
it for like 1000 years maybe like
50 years we want the flavor of the fish
we cook it to medium well this is a fish
that is beautiful if it's slightly
undercooked
our pico de gallo a little bit of morita
sauce morita is a smoked
dry chile a little drizzle of that helps
accentuate the sweetness of the fish
all right guys this is the wood grilled
kampachi fish taco
awesome can you smell that oh yeah look
at this giant chunk of meat
taco cheers
[Music]
damn it that's good that is ridiculous
with the fear of sounding hyperbolic
this is the most perfectly blended
balance
of ingredients i think i've had in a
taco before this might be the best
constructed single bite of fish i've
ever had
including the best sushi i've ever had
oh no
you've had the best sushi in the world
this is right up there with it what more
can you say it was over too soon but
another thing that i would like you guys
to try is aguachile it's a northern
mexican thing very very popular in
sonora
california it's a marinade made with
lime juice water
cilantro and spicy green serrano peppers
we add a little bit of cucumber to it to
give it a little bit of sweetness we're
going to be pairing it with beautiful
santa barbara spot prawns one of the
great products of southern california
marinated in the agua chile a little bit
of avocado then we fry up the heads of
the ponds and serve them as a crispy
garnish on the plate it's a great little
appetizer what should be my first bite
uh the head
the head really
incredible the crunch of the shell why
are we not eating shrimp like this all
the time
i'm gonna start with a little scallop
action
oh god this is crazy yeah it's sweet
like fruit
it's ocean fruit oh my gosh
this shrimp is ridiculous whoa the first
thing i noticed was the plumpness
it's incredibly plump plum you know like
people who've gone too far with their
lip filler and it's uncomfortably
plumbed this is
borderline uncomfortably plump
[Music]
one of our most popular dishes also
pulpo in
octopus in its own ink in a taco fish
taco location
chew taste test take two
the octopus taco is a very traditional
yucatan style recipe which is where i'm
from here we do
a version of that where the tinta the
incomponent is made into a sofrito and
then the octopus is fried and served
on top of the ink that sounds great
oh it's really warm i've never had a
fried octopus before
cheers
okay where are we where are we
where in the world do you eat octopus
and it is
soft still plump crispy on the outside
and juicy
dude it looks like a cheese stick
i'm going to be thinking about that fish
taco for a long time
i'm going to be thinking about that
aguachile for a long time
so earlier we had an ice cream taco it's
time for another sweet treat we're
having ice cream again
but this time what it's in a fish
oh whoa how have i never had this before
everybody touch fish cheers
mmm mine has red bean inside
oh i just dripped on myself guys i made
a fish taco
in 2017 14 of seafood
fished in the u.s was used for fish oil
what
and fish meal and animal food i mean my
cat does eat a lot of fish products i
think your cat should be on this worth
it episode ooh i wonder if i could make
a cat food fish taco oh
he probably doesn't know what a taco is
though so i don't know if you
know how to eat it so for our last stop
tomorrow we're going to
connie seafood she will be serving us a
whole grilled fish
that we will eat as tacos
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is connie casio i'm owner of
connie seafood and today
i'll be serving pescado sarandiado this
is a cooking style yes you have to be
flipping it back and forth
so sarandiado means means flipping fish
connie seafood started in our backyard
in 1989
my dad was a founder he's from nayari
mexico the cooking is simple
you know it's just a little salt pepper
little lime and you can taste the
quality and so that's what i represent
first we have the whole fish
we butterfly it add a little margarine
salt and then my special sauce and then
we put it to grill
face down first where all the meat is at
because it's a longer cooking process
it's about 25 to 30 minute process we
have
sliced red onions a little bit of
margarine soy sauce a little bit of salt
and that's it the green sauce it's a
traditional nayeri green salsa serrano
limes water and salt if you go to all
the seafood places have that
and is there a reason why you wanted to
maintain that camino style
i thought my customers were glad to come
out and enjoy the whole fish just the
way
i would enjoy when i was 12 years old my
dad would take us to the beach and we'd
get a large fish
there's a fine balance between telling
customers to do too much or too little
like i don't want to cook my own food
but i do want to like participate in the
making of it absolutely yeah
i'll cook it for you you serve it the
michelada for you
and the palomas for me cheers cheers
[Music]
my body's tingling this looks incredible
look at the sheen
look how juicy this is i think we should
try the fish on its own
that's a choice piece
oh why is it when i make fish it's not
like this
knowing you can be any number of reasons
okay i'm gonna do connie's recommended
construction first
fish caramelized onions a little green
sauce that's
it you know what i just realized
the reason that we probably build these
is because you get to like you
get to start to salivate as you're
preparing your dish yeah
anticipation starts to build up as
you're getting into that in the whole
time
you make a taco here so
[Music]
yo that's salsa though sophisticated
flavor oh my gosh
steven's designer bite is coming up next
i'm gonna add some of the crispy parts
here
caramelized onions fresh red onion of
course cucumber
and i'm adding a chip because it's there
when you give me options i'll take all
of them you're a monster you know
you jealous when you started i was like
there's no way this isn't going to end
up looking stupid but now i'm looking at
tacos it looks pretty fun
[Music]
what's the verdict heck yeah i want to
try this it's really the crunch that
i added here i think cucumber is my
favorite part i can imagine eating this
on a beach oh for sure
steve and i brought you back to the
beach thank you very much we've had our
fish tacos it's sunset on another worth
its story
time to decide okay which fish taco
what's the most worth it
to you the worth of winner is holbox
there was so much on that menu that i
could easily go back three more times
and not eat any of the same food who's
your worth at winner okay look
i would eat all of them all the time but
to my worth at winter also
goes to holbox the wood flavor plus the
yellowtail made this beautiful thing
that just yeah steamed my mouth i
couldn't stop thinking about it here's
the thing
each fish taco today had a special
occasion
where you would eat it ricky's is the
go-to pole bosch
a date night and then connie seafood
that's the group gathering taco spot
adam who's your worth it winner
adam says whole bosch annie who's your
worth a winner okay
okay good night and good luck i'm gonna
go that way
should we finally touch the ocean let's
go touch the ocean
[Music]
watch out there's a bike coming
[Music]
jump in this volleyball game real quick
[Music]